bientôt la fin de vingt ans de
restauration des travaux pour redonner
une jeunesse à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt la dernière phase concerne la
toiture du bas côté de l'édifice datant
du xiième siècle une intervention menée
par un cabinet d'architecturé spécialisé
dans le patrimoine historique la pente
étant inférieur au pourcentage de mise
en oeuvre de la tuile plate
traditionnelle qu'on met en oeuvre
actuellement on était obligé de réaliser
une sous toiture en zinc c'est les
travaux d'étanchéité de la toiture
puisqu'il y avait des infiltrations
d'eau est maintenant à ce jour on a
réalisé l'ensemble de la toiture
oui ça veut dire que sauf accident
particulier on va être tranquille pour
une période voit un siècle voire un
siècle et demi
l'église saint victor a connu une longue
cure de rajeunissement de son intérieur
à l'installation du chauffage à la
toiture et au parvis devant le bâtiment
l'investissement total de la ville
avoisine les 1,5 million d'euros il
fallait faire toute façon comme c'est un
monument historique veulent absolument
que la ville s'engage à restaurer
l'église
l'important c'est de voir avant et après
est ce que cela attire beaucoup de
personnes pour venir à cette église
c'est quand même une église qui est de
moyen âge qui la décorent xiième siècle
allait pour ceux déjà qu'ils font là qui
suivent le culte et puis il ya aussi le
fait je vous dis sympa un bâtiment
important quand même les bâtisses
historiques un domaine important pour la
commune chaque année la ville engage
600000 euros dans son budget pour
l'entretien du patrimoine